projet subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes
nous entendons aujourd'hui ensemble les
représentants de trois associations
parmi les 17 associations qui ont
bénéficié du fond Marianne nous avons
donc monsieur Abdenour Bidart président
de fraternité générale qui est
accompagnée de Madame Fabienne savencher
membre du bureau et de Monsieur Baptiste
laroudé Taz délégué Tazi Tazi c'est
mieux déléguer général Monsieur Xavier
desmaisons présidente Civic Fab
et Monsieur Rudy Richard
qui est directeur de conspiration watch
chacune de vos associations nous a
transmis des éléments écrits en réponse
aux questionnaires qui vous a été
adressé et ne vous en remercions lors de
son audition le 16 mai dernier le
secrétaire général du comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance de la radicalisation
Monsieur Christian Gravel nous a fait
part des difficultés à trouver des
associations en mesure de répondre aux
objectifs du fond de Marianne je le cite
si la mobilisation du secteur associatif
constitue un levé un levier essentiel
pour déployer sur internet un discours
républicain crédible rares sont les
associations qui sont à la fois mesures
d'agir contre le séparatisme et de
maîtriser les techniques de la
communication digitale
nous attendons donc de votre audition
que vous puissiez nous préciser à la
fois vos domaines de compétence mais
également la manière dont vous avez
répondu à l'appel apogée et les actions
que vous avez menées pour répondre aux
objectifs poursuivis avant de vous céder
la parole pour un bref pour point
introductif et quand je dis bref c'est
réellement bref 400 minutes je dois vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
une commission d'enquête et passive de
sanctions pénales qui peuvent aller
selon les circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende
donc je vous invite à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
elle avait la main droite et dites je le
jure tout d'abord monsieur abdenordidart
et donc je vais également le demander à
Madame Fabienne sans manger qui serait
peut-être appelé
merci et Monsieur Baptiste la roue des
États-Unis
merci qui pourrait donc tous les deux
s'exprimer en complément de Monsieur
Bidart Monsieur Xavier des maisons
merci et Monsieur Rudy Reichstadt
merci Monsieur donc je vous laisse à
présent la parole pour un bref pour un
truc si vous le souhaitez bien entendu
monsieur Bidart en premier
[Musique]
et notre credo laïque bien entendu à
fraternité générale depuis le début et
que nous ne réussirons à lutter contre
que si nous sommes capables en même
temps de lutter pour c'est à dire que
nous ne réussirons à endiguer
véritablement le séparatisme ou les
séparatisme et à réparer le tissu
déchiré de notre société qu'à la
condition et bien que nous donnions à
aimer les valeurs républicaines et que
nous donnions avoir à l'oeuvre celles et
ceux qui au jour le jour s'engagent pour
elle pour les faire vivre de telle sorte
que ces valeurs ne restent pas des
idéaux de Fronton mais qu'elles
deviennent si je parle comme les
antiques des vertus c'est à dire des
manières d'agir de se comporter dans la
société voilà pourquoi depuis 2016 a
fraternité générale nous faisons ce que
nous aimons faire et ce que nous savons
faire c'est à dire que nous donnons à
voir tout ce qui se fait dans la France
d'aujourd'hui pour réparer le tissu
social c'est-à-dire que nous donnons
avoir toutes ces associations qui
travaillent chacune dans un domaine au
quotidien à réparer ce tissu afin de les
mettre en visibilité c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'agit par cette mise en visibilité de
leur donner davantage confiance
conscience de leur force sur le mode du
vous n'êtes pas tout seul à agir là où
vous êtes mais vous faites partie d'un
grand mouvement
et puis évidemment à effet de contagion
à effet communicatif c'est-à-dire que le
but est en montrant ce qui a dit
agissent déjà de mettre en mouvement
ceux qui n'agissent pas encore par un
effet je disais de contagion ou de
galvanisation du désir d'engagement bon
nous le faisons à travers un certain
nombre d'actions de quatre grands types
vous nous avez demandé d'être rapide
donc je vais être synthétique tout
d'abord une action en ligne nous
travaillons énormément sur les réseaux
sociaux je pourrais détailler cela tout
à l'heure si vous le souhaitez nous le
faisons en les quand je dis les réseaux
sociaux ce sont ceux dont les gens de ma
génération sont familiers Facebook et
Twitter et ce pour lesquelles je confie
à Monsieur Baptiste laraudettazi toute
la confiance nécessaire parce qu'il
s'agit de Tik Tok et d'Instagram autant
dire pour moi quelque chose qui est un
petit peu loin de mes bases donc nous
sommes sur ces réseaux sociaux avec
cette vocation justement par ces médias
jeunes de toucher la jeunesse la
jeunesse quand on dit la jeunesse comme
ça c'est un terme un petit peu passe
partout ce sont les citoyens demain
comment est-ce qu'on va les amener à se
sentir appartenir à quelque chose de
plus grand que qu'il les dépasse et qui
les appelle et qui s'appelle la nation
bon donc une action en ligne une action
audiovisuelle depuis 2016 nous proposons
avec un partenariat notamment avec
France Télévisions TF1 M6 tout un
ensemble de médias un partenariat de
diffusion de clips qui mettent en scène
la fraternité voilà comment la
fraternité se fait au jour le jour dans
notre société donc chaque année nous
avons une campagne de clip qui est
diffusée par l'ensemble de nos grands
médias nationaux ce qui en termes
d'impact à quelque chose d'absolument
considérable et d'ailleurs petite incise
en réalité au-delà de ces médias
audiovisuels c'est aussi pour cela qu'on
va vers les réseaux c'est à dire que
quand on est une association aujourd'hui
on peut organiser des événements
physiques et c'est ce que nous avons
fait aussi avec parfois une grande
valeur symbolique nous avons organisé il
y a quelques années la première chaîne
humaine autour des remparts de
Carcassonne c'est à dire plus de 2000
personnes qui se tenaient la main et qui
symbolisait justement et bien la France
qui se rassemble mais il est évident que
si nous voulons avoir un impact plus
important il faut aller au-delà de ces
événements physiques donc une action en
ligne une action audiovisuelle une
action événementielle nous avons
organisée pendant des années des dîners
en couleur des dîner en couleurs c'est à
dire des dîners qui rassemblent toutes
les classes sociales toutes les couleurs
si vous voulez
sociopolitico culture à l'eau ethnique
de notre société pour montrer une France
qui vit bien une capable d'une France
qui est capable de se mélanger de se
respecter de se comprendre de
s'entreconnaître etc de la même manière
nous avons organisé dans un certain
nombre de territoires un nombre Baptiste
dira sans doute le chiffre exact de
tournoi de football donc l'idée c'est
véritablement de créer des opportunités
pour les gens de se rencontrer en vrai
là où d'habitude et bien on est chacun
chez soi ou chacun de son côté et puis
quatrième dimension de cette action donc
en ligne audiovisuelle événementiel
l'action éducative nous avons créé il y
a quelques années qui est en voie
d'amélioration à peu près permanente une
mallette pédagogique une mallette
pédagogique dans laquelle nous proposons
un kit de débat fraternel nous les
appelons comme ça qui dans un langage
extrêmement simple peuvent être utilisés
par des professeurs de l'école par des
animateurs de quartiers ou
d'associations par des éducateurs pour
inviter les jeunes à venir discuter
autour des valeurs de la République en
particulier la fraternité mais également
la laïcité un sujet
au double du temps
mais bon voilà vous avez présenté le
4ème aura l'occasion vous aurez
l'occasion de redévelopper sur quelques
exemples précis je vais poursuivre avec
Monsieur des maisons s'il veut bien
bon on se rejoint mais prenez le micro
prenez le micro
on se rejoint un petit peu avec avec
Abdennour sur les valeurs sur l'ensemble
de d'éléments du projet
bon nous on est l'association Civic FAF
donc on a fait tôt nos 13 ans il y a
quelques mois une quinzaine de membres
tous bénévoles dont je fais partie
la plupart spécialistes du numérique
directeur artistique
spécialiste de la communication sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis des acteurs
engagés dans la ville de la cité une
quinzaine de ces bénévoles pilotent une
quinzaine de personnes
dirigée par une déléguée générale qui
déploie le travail sur le terrain en
ligne et hors ligne alors notre sujet à
nous même si on se rejoint évidemment il
sait l'esprit critique c'est notre notre
prise de notre position à nous notre
positionnement
alors qu'est-ce que je veux par là c'est
c'est une façon de retrouver un peu le
une partie de l'appel à projet notamment
le défendre des valeurs républicaines de
liberté de conscience d'expression enfin
je vous passe toutes toute la phrase
pourquoi parce que chacun chacune a bien
vu que sur Internet la la mobilisation
d'un centre de public la les procédures
algorithmiques font que
la haine peut primer sur la haine des
discours de colère des discours
rapides leur vie d'en découdre peuvent
primer sur
disons des discours plus
pacifiques plus
réflexifront aussi plus bienveillant
voilà
chacun enfin maintenant toutes ces
choses là sont extrêmement documentées
donc pour vous donner un petit exemple
pour chaque mot d'indignation ajouter un
tweet le taux de retweet augmente au
moyen de 17%
donc on rajoute 5 6 mots on commence à
pouvoir faire le buzz et c'est ça notre
sujet donc civique femme nous
intervenons en ligne mais aussi je l'ai
dit via des actions et des ateliers qui
mélangent le physique et le numérique
dans le langage du marketing on appelle
ça le figal et là on va appeler ça des
ateliers créatifs on dispose d'une
communauté importante sur les réseaux
sociaux donc plus de 300 000 fans sur
Facebook
et l'ensemble nous amène plus 350 000
personnes qui suivent
nos communications nos contenus et qui
nous permettent d'avoir un peu de
puissance de frappe plusieurs de nos
vidéos dépassent le million de vues
jusqu'à trois quatre millions likez
commentez partagez donc avec un succès
en tout cas dans un une partie du public
de ces contenus
notre public c'est un public jeune nous
on s'adresse au 13 27 ans pour
l'essentiel
c'est en public que qui n'entend pas se
voir imposer des discours de sachant
mais dans un même temps qui se
questionne beaucoup qui se construit
donc c'est en public qui n'est pas dupe
mais en même temps qui est très
perméable à des contenus qu'il capte en
permanence sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui est du coup pour eux aux théories du
complot manipulation
c'est un public qui est assez propre
code qui est assez réflexions qui a ses
approches qui a ses modes qui changent
rapidement et on a vu des mêmes
personnes sur plusieurs années évoluer
complètement échanger de revirer
complètement de mode de vie d'usage de
coutume et de d'opinion c'est en public
il faut intéresser sinon il décroche il
est ultra volatile et il a parfois connu
des expériences de vie difficiles voire
très difficile que je vous n’épargner
nos ateliers de terrain les remontées
sont par moments
frappantes glaçons triste dans dans le
réel qu'on peut voir au plus près des
jeunes un peu partout en France alors
c'est pour eux qu'on travaille
c'est difficile mais satisfaisant pour
l'équipe et du coup on a une démarche
qui que je voulais vous expliquer en
quelques mots
qui prend la mesure de la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre on a une démarche qui
n'est pas stigmatisante donc nous
n'arrivons jamais avec un discours sur
vous êtes complotiste vous ne comprenez
rien vous êtes dangereux on essaie
d'amener chacun chacune par une démarche
d'échange d'informations à améliorer sa
réflexion sans prétention aucune sachant
que tous ces mécanismes digitaux
algorithmiques nous les vivons tous et
nous en sommes tous porteurs donc chacun
chacune peut aussi faire des raccourcis
aller trop vite
d'agressivité nous n'avons pas de
position de sachange je l'ai déjà dit et
puis
nous nous inscrivons nous d'une certaine
manière dans une forme de démocratie
délibérative un philosophe allemand
récent a combien un petit ouvrage on se
demandant si effectivement elle a l'air
des réseaux sociaux la délibération qui
fait le cœur de de nos démocraties la
capacité à échanger à échanger des
arguments à 100 ans à s'écouter et à
essayer de se retrouver sur un commun
était peut-être
en train de disparaître
cet ouvrage 2022 traduire 2023 à la NRF
alors c'est pas parce que on arrive et
qu'on pousse la délibération et la
discussion qu'on fait n'importe quoi
nous arrivons avec des intervenants qui
sont formés
certains par le cipdr ils doivent être
capables d'aborder des sujets complexes
des questions complexes qui se posent
parfois sociales parfois des opinions et
donc il faut pouvoir réagir de façon la
plus raisonnable la plus structurée la
plus document c'est possible en ligne et
hors ligne on a un double contrôle sur
nos ateliers avec des animateurs formés
je l'ai dit je des professeurs qui sont
présents quand on intervient dans des
écoles ou des collèges où et les
animateurs eux-mêmes nous construisons à
partir de documents à partir de films à
partir de d'éléments historiques de
référence et puis nous demandons à ces
jeunes publics quand il est possible de
produire quelque chose un travail écrit
une chanson un tableau des vidéos
surtout beaucoup des vidéos numériques
parce que ça aussi leur permet de
décoder la façon dont se fait la
production de contenu et comment elle
peut aussi être travaillée Jean-Philippe
je pourrais développer donc nos
programmes ils ont pour objectif de
développer l'esprit critique avec une
démarche créative et je ne dis pas que
c'est la seule méthode c'est tout le
sens que j'ai pensé du fond Marianne qui
était d'essayer d'agréger différentes
approches différents types
d'associations qui pouvaient se
retrouver dans un commun qui est les
valeurs de la République mais chacune
avec leur approche personnel limité mais
intéressantes merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
pour l'occasion que vous nous donnez
aujourd'hui de nous exprimer devant vous
très rapidement sur conspiration c'est
un site internet créé en 2007 qui s'est
professionnalisé à partir de 2017 et
devenu un service de presse en ligne qui
est édité par une association loi 1901
qui est l'Observatoire du
conspirationnisme je ne suis pas
Président je suis le directeur parce que
je suis salarié de cette structure et je
suis à la fois le directeur de
publication et de la rédaction
c'est un site internet
qui donc existe depuis plus de 15 ans
qui est une antéorité une expertise
reconnue sur ce sujet
le fond Marianne a servi à aider des
acteurs de la lutte contre la RA en
ligne l'Observatoire du conspirisme en
étant et c'est même l'un des plus
unanimements reconnus pour le sérieux de
son action et la solidité de son travail
sur le complotisme et c'est à ce titre
là que nous avons été soutenus dans le
cadre de l'appel à projet font mariage
s'agissant des différentes activités que
nous menons outre l'animation de ce
service de presse en ligne c'est
évidemment la production d'enquête
originale sur le phénomène complotiste
c'est l'animation de réseaux sociaux
avec un compte Twitter très suivi plus
de 60 000 abonnés la conception d'une
newsletter hebdomadaire le projet
riposte qui est celui qui est soutenu
co-financé par le cipdr depuis 2019
maintenant qu'il a été de nouveau en
la réalisation d'une émission les
déconspirateurs pour Youtube
qui bénéficie d'un cofinancement de la
dilkra la délégation est un mystère la
lutte contre le racisme antimitisme et
la haine anti LGBT c'est la
participation
à l'organisation chaque année des
Assises Nationales de la lutte contre
négationnisme y compris dans cette salle
il me semble il y a deux ou trois ans
maintenant sont des interventions auprès
des professionnels de l'éducation qui
vise à sensibiliser aux enjeux de la
désinformation et du conspirationnisme
la participation à l'Observatoire de la
haine en ligne sous l'égide de l'arcome
à la définition également du plan
national contre le racisme antimitives
mais discriminations liées à l'origine
je m'arrête là et je répondrai à toutes
les questions que la représentation
nationale se poserait sur tous ces
sujets
merci beaucoup alors nous avons proposé
avec le rapporteur général donc mes
collègues de la commission une table
ronde c'est donc pas pour traiter
chacune des associations de manière
indépendante et si je puis dire en série
mais c'est plutôt pour vous faire réagir
un certain nombre de sujets et nous dire
un petit peu de manière à ce que l'on
perçoit bien finalement quelle est la
relation des associations qui ont
candidaté avec le cpdr d'un côté comment
le fond Marianne finalement est venu
percuter ou modifier finalement les
choses comment vous l'avez perçu et
comment ça se continue après le fond
Marianne déjà vous l'avez évoqué avec un
budget pour 2023 par exemple donc est
déjà hors fond Marianne si je puis dire
voilà donc dans un premier temps je vais
peut-être vous demander alors cette
formule si elle veut si on veut qu'elle
soit un peu dynamique aussi évidemment
ça appelle des réponses un peu assez
serrées assez courte
de manière à ce qu'on puisse quitte à y
revenir
voir un petit peu l'ensemble du sujet
donc je vais démarrer parce que si vous
voulez bien avec quelques questions
générales puis le rapporteur général
viendra après sur des questions un peu
plus un peu plus pointues si je puis
dire la première le premier sujet c'est
effectivement comment comment se font
les financements quel est votre relation
historique avec le cipdr
dans le temps donc comment le fond
Marianne s'inscrit là-dedans et comment
vous l'avez comment dire senti ou
compris par rapport à ce que fait déjà
le cpda parce que fondamentalement il y
a pas d'argent supplémentaire c'est
presque une appellation une label comme
a dit d'ailleurs le secrétaire général
une labellisation d'une certaine façon
de ne pas particuliers ou d'un sujet
particulier au sein du CPI PDR donc
comment vous l'avez vu quels sont aussi
pour les pour les autres les autres
financements alors je vous demande pas
les noms mais autre financement public
et la part de financement privé s'il y
en a ou financement hors publics en tout
cas
qui existe qu'on connaît une bonne
vision de la manière dont les systèmes
fonctionnent je redémarre par Monsieur
Reichstett dans l'autre sens pour
changer l'ordre un peu mais si vous
voulez bien en deux trois minutes un peu
voilà comme vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs
la première fois mais donc précisément
sur quoi quel est votre question
ma question c'est de faire le lien entre
depuis quand vous travaillez PDF le
l'arrivée du fond Marianne d'accord ça a
changé et ça changeait est-ce que ça se
continue aujourd'hui est-ce que l'action
lancer se poursuit aujourd'hui avec
d'autres types de financement quels sont
les types quel est le poids du public
finalement public par rapport à
l'ensemble de financement voilà
alors nous avons commencé à prendre
contact avec le cipdr en 2018
et ces échanges se sont traduits par une
demande de subvention formulée en 2019
et donc un premier financement sur un
projet expérimental qui pour nous
s'appelle ripos c'est le seul projet
cofinancé par le cpdr un projet
expérimental qui consiste je grandir
quelques mots
à percer les bulles de filtre dans
lesquelles sont enfermés les internautes
c'est-à-dire très concrètement les
exposés à des contenus à la diversité
internationale c'est ce que on peut
appeler aussi du prêt booking
et en gros il s'agit pour des gens qui
vont rechercher des termes liés à la
culture complotiste par exemple nouvel
ordre mondial great reset état profond
et ces choses là ou des noms de de
médias complotistes notoires et bien
qu'il trouve des contenus produits par
notre rédaction en premier et pour cela
donc nous produire des contenus des
articles des notices en l'occurrence
ce projet il est centré sur des notices
d'information très documentées très
sourcés
très informés et régulièrement mis à
jour surtout et c'est notice nous les
poussons ensuite
via des coupons publicitaires qui sont
mis à notre disposition parce que nous
sommes associations à bidon lucratif
dans le cadre d'un programme s'appelle
Google ad grant voilà donc c'est du
droit de tirage de coupon publicitaire
qui pour nous est neutre budgétairement
et qui participent complètement de cette
action donc nous avons eu
un premier lancement de cette opération
pour l'année 2019-2020 ont fonctionné
par saison à l'époque c'est à dire
printemps 2019 après un temps 2020 on a
réajuster le tir pour l'année suivante
parce que on n'avait pas pu notamment
dépenser toute l'enveloppe ou pas pas
complètement du projet initial sachant
que l'enveloppe quand je parle
d'enveloppe c'est le projet le coût du
projet global
et il n'est financé qu'à hauteur des
deux tiers par la subvention du cpdr
quelques éléments s'agissant de la part
des financements publics dans notre
budget nous avons pris la décision
depuis que nous avons commencé à avoir
un budget de limiter de plafonner à 50%
en tout cas en dessous de 50%, la part
du financement public dans notre budget
global
parce que il nous semble que c'est 100
de le faire comme ça sauf la première
année ici je comprends bien où il y
avait 70%, c'est ipdr ce que vous avez
dit mais là vous parlez de l'action
uniquement moi je parle de bouger global
de l'association ok oui je parle de
budget global de l'association pas de
l'action
pour nos collègues donner une comment
dirais une estimation de l'évolution de
votre budget
du budget global de la sauce vous dire
écoutez depuis combien de temps depuis
2023 écoutez on a dû passer
je pense qu'on est passé de autour de
150000 à autour de 230 000 aujourd'hui
voilà on est on est dans ces dans cet
étage là
donc nous avons choisi de ne jamais
excéder 50% chaque année de financement
public dans notre budget global
qu'est-ce que je peux ajouter sur la
manière sensation donc 2019-2020
premiers financement cpdr 2020-2021
segon financement et en 2021 nous avons
été orientés vers l'appel à projet voilà
quand il s'était agit de renouveler la
demande et du coup nous avons franchi un
palier nous avons demandé plus que ce
que nous avons obtenu l'année précédente
parce que il y avait ce contexte lié au
drame que vous savez de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et nous nous
savions que nous pouvions absorber
ce financement travailler à cette
hauteur là d'accord et depuis 2023 vous
continuez sur le même niveau exactement
ça s'appelle plus fond Marianne
absolument très bien c'est des maisons
même question
[Musique]
président monsieur le rapporteur mettez
le micro c'est est-ce que vous
m'entendez oui
le fond Marianne alors nous nous
travaillons avec le cipdr depuis 2016
nous avons proposé un projet assez
proche de ce qui est devenu un de nos
formats qui s'appelle nuance qui est une
plateforme numérique de communiquer
enfin de production de contenu
orienté sur les valeurs de la République
et l'esprit critique
nous avions proposé ensemble d'autres
dispositifs qui n'avaient pas été retenu
à l'époque et donc ça c'était un petit
peu après les événements de Charlie
Hebdo puisque c'est de ce moment là que
date notre relation avec le cipdr et
auparavant nous en tant que de expert du
digital nous étions très intéressés sur
la problématique de la haine en ligne
avec le lancement d'un observatoire
qui essayait qui était le premier du
genre qui était dans le cadre de travaux
de recherche dans ce qu'on appelle le
high speech et qui essayait de
comprendre cette montée de la violence
sur les réseaux sociaux le fond Marianne
on a toujours
régulièrement eu des relations avec le
cipdr
par moments plus ou moins importantes
suivant les époques et les moments le
fond Marianne a été l'occasion de de
donner à nos projets davantage
d'envergure
ça c'est le premier point une envergure
financière un petit peu plus importantes
je crois que c'est notre budget le plus
important annuel
l'année du fond Marianne
elle nous a permis de travailler sur des
nouveaux projets des nouveaux programmes
alors on a lancé notamment un format qui
s'appelle mémorama qui sont des ateliers
auprès de jeunes publics adossés et
souvent d'ailleurs en milieu scolaire
mais pas que
adossé sur de la qui travaille la
mémoire de la guerre d'Algérie
la mémoire l'histoire qui essaie de
faire réfléchir ensemble de jeunes
publics sur des contenus sérieux sur ce
cet événement qui s'est passé et dont on
avait la date anniversaire on a testé
aussi d'autres formats notamment un
format qui s'appelle mixité qui essaie
de faire rencontrer des publics de
différentes catégories
socio-professionnelles de différents
lieux géographiques ou de différents
âges donc amener des jeunes dans un
EHPAD et faire essayer de d'enclencher
des relations
ateliers qui a assez bien fonctionné
et qui a été durable c'est à dire qu'on
a eu après des jeunes qui sont revenus
dans les pages voilà
on a testé aussi des nouveaux contenus
et des nouveaux formats pardon vous
interrompre à ce stade vous nous avez
dit tout à l'heure que à ce stade vous
êtes autour de 350 000 followers je vais
le dire comme ça
vraiment sur un public jeune vous avez
dit 13 27 c'est vraiment le les 80% de
la cible oui on est à 74% sur cette pour
être précis enfin c'est le chiffre qu'on
a que les plateformes nous donnent
puisque j'ai plus la question tout à
l'heure à votre voisin monsieur
Reichstadt l'évolution des budget de
votre assos entre entre 2010 et 2023
grosso modo je dirais qu'elle augmente
d'un tiers mais je n'ai pas le détail
précis donc là je voudrais pas vous dire
de soutisme mais voilà d'accord et la
part de financement public alors part de
financement public ça a évolué aussi
dans le temps l'année du fond Marianne
on a plutôt un financement public
principalement mais probablement 20%
privé il a pu arriver qu'on soit
beaucoup plus en financement privé le
financement privé sur ces thématiques là
et quand même assez complexe alors ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle privé dans les
entreprises qui peuvent intervenir vous
pouvez avoir les grandes plateformes
chacune un programme enfin plus ou moins
élaboré certaines très élaborées pour
essayer de travailler le
éventuellement les externalités
négatives qui pourraient générer leur
plateforme ou qui pourraient essayer de
d'amener du contenu positif aider des
contenus positifs à faire donc il a pu
arriver qu'on travaille avec ces
plateformes et qu'on travaille encore on
travaille avec des associations aussi
des préfectures souvent qui nous
demandent d'intervenir sur des des
quartiers spécifiques prioritaires de la
ville et puis et puis voilà pour parfois
des écoles je pense des bénévoles du
milieu économique vous même d'ailleurs
vous en faites partie est-ce que
quelques entreprises
vous soutiennent tout de même c'est en
projet c'est plutôt le projet qu'une
réalité plus un projet qu'une réalité
d'accord merci
c'est bizarre
merci monsieur le Président
alors Fabienne servant Schreber qui a
fondé fraternité générale avec moi était
en contact avec le avec le cipdr depuis
la campagne à l'eau anti-aad qu'elle a
initié en 2015 peut-être que vous
souhaiterez l'interroger à ce à ce sujet
puisque tout part de là il s'agissait
alors d'assurer la réalisation d'une
série de clips cherchant à faire
connaître le numéro vert stop djihadisme
mis en place par le gouvernement voilà
et à partir du moment en 2016 où nous
avons créé fraternité générale donc un
an plus tard nous avons été en contact
régulier avec les différents
responsables c'est à dire les
responsables successifs du cpdr le
préfet Ngan madame Domenach le
préférence et puis le préfet Gravel et
de mon côté j'ai rencontré le préfet
Gravel
d'abord dans le cadre de mes fonctions
je suis président
bénévole de fraternité générale je suis
inspecteur général de l'Éducation
nationale du sport et de la recherche et
je siège à ce titre dans le conseil des
sages de la laïcité donc je travaille
moi-même au sein du ministère de
l'Éducation beaucoup sur ces questions
de fraternité transmission des valeurs
laïcité etc et je me souviens que assez
tôt j'avais sensibilisé le préfet Gravel
à la nécessité dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire relative au fait
de lutter pour c'est à dire de
promouvoir véritablement de manière
positive dans l'esprit de nos jeunes
concitoyens ces valeurs que sont la
fraternité la laïcité etc et cette dans
cette direction exactement que
l'association
a sollicité le cipdr c'est-à-dire que
nous voulions constituer de la manière
la plus solide qui soit cette mallette
pédagogique dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure et puis nous souhaitions avoir
une action sur les réseaux sociaux pour
promouvoir au quotidien la fraternité et
les valeurs de la République encore une
fois à destination des jeunes et donc le
18 janvier 2021 nous avons obtenu un
rendez-vous avec le le secrétaire
général du cipdr donc Christian Gravel
et avec celle qui était notre
interlocutrice je dirais habituel sa
collaboratrice Charlotte Collonges voilà
et donc en réalité le la possibilité
ouverte par le cipdr au moment de la
création du fond Marianne était la
suivante de notre point de vue nous
voulions véritablement renforcer notre
action sur les réseaux sociaux puisque
encore une fois nous vous l'avons
expliqué
les médias c'est notre partie il
n'empêche qu'il nous fallait une équipe
il nous fallait une équipe formée il
nous fallait une équipe opérationnelle
il nous fallait pardonnez-moi
l'expression une force de frappe
digitale et il nous fallait pour
s'adresser à des jeunes il nous fallait
des jeunes et donc nous souhaitions
véritablement
rassemblé une équipe autour de la
compétence directrice de Monsieur
Baptiste laraudettazi et c'est donc si
vous voulez à cela ou de cela que le
fond Marianne nous a donné l'opportunité
constitué véritablement une équipe pour
être extrêmement présent sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment ce dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure Tik Tok et
Instagram une équipe que nous aurions eu
le moyen et que nous avons eu le moyen
de salarié et lorsque nous l'avons
salarié une équipe que nous avons eu les
moyens de former parce que il s'agit de
former par je dirais simplement à
l'usage général des réseaux sociaux mais
comment est-ce qu'on fait sur les
réseaux sociaux pour produire un contre
discours c'est à dire un discours qui
appelle à se rencontrer plutôt qu'à se
casser haïr voilà donc le premier
rapport outre financier bien entendu du
cipdr a été d'offrir à notre équipe les
opportunités d'une formation donc
véritablement les jeunes que nous avons
recrutés ont pu bénéficier de cette
formation au cipdr et de cette
alimentation par le cipdr de toute une
information c'est à dire que chaque mois
l'équipe recevait des documents qui
étaient fournis justement par Sherlock
Collomb sous la forme d'une sorte de
newsletter qui était une sorte de
décryptage je dirais de la
radicalisation et de tout ce qui
tournait je dirais comme une nébuleuse
autour de ce sujet de la radicalisation
et de la déradicalisation voilà donc une
formation et puis ensuite une action
parce que c'est de ça je pense donc vous
ce que vous voulez entendre concrètement
alors sur Instagram et sur Tik Tok tout
d'abord alors je parle sous le contrôle
de Mathis là-haut des Tazi qui a suivi
de ça de plus près que moi mais nous
avons
fait un véritable bon dans notre
capacité à toucher la jeunesse le public
cette jeunesse justement sur Instagram
c'est
67,5% de notre public qui a entre 12 et
25 ans sur TikTok c'est
71% entre 18 et 25 ans nous avons
comptabilisé justement en vue de pouvoir
fournir un résultat objectif un certain
nombre d'interactions donc sur Tik Tok
c'est pour moi ces chiffres pardon sont
un peu abstraits mais je pense qu'ils
font foi de de l'activité ces
interactions sont de l'ordre de 100800
avec un nom un nombre de
comment on appelle ça le Baptiste si tu
peux venir mon secours un nombre de
clics de compte atteints voilà un
certain nombre de comptes atteints qui
est particulièrement important alors
c'est pas oui voilà j'ai ce nombre de
contacts sur Instagram c'est 7 millions
de comptes atteints un peu plus de 7
millions nous avons nous vous avons
fourni le chiffre exact et puis sur Tik
Tok c'est un peu plus de 3,8 millions de
comptes atteints mais je voudrais
préciser encore quelque chose si vous le
permettez c'est que et bien
quelque chose qui est relatif au contenu
de ce que nous donnons avoir sur Tik Tok
et sur Instagram en réalité nous sommes
dans notre attirer notre cœur de cible
ou notre cœur de métier c'est à dire que
nous donnons avoir la vie associative
voilà donc nous avons pu valoriser plus
de 300 associations qui travaillent
pardon pour cette expression qui est
devenue un petit peu je dirais
passe-partout mais qui travaille au
vivant ensemble à réparer ou à
raccommoder le vivre ensemble ça va de
gens qui font des maraudes à des gens
qui travaillent dans le milieu carcéral
etc etc donc nous donnant à voir et
d'ailleurs pas seulement dans notre
société française mais nous élargissons
aussi la focale de telle sorte que et
bien les jeunes que nous touchons
s'aperçoivent que la fraternité c'est
pas une obsession française ou une Libye
française mais véritablement quelque
chose qui se cherche aujourd'hui au
niveau international il y a une autre
façon de vivre ensemble que
l'individualisme l'égoïsme etc etc
vous pouvez nous rappeler comme vous
prédécesseurs le pourcentage d'aide
publique
dans l'ensemble du budget tout à fait en
2022 par exemple voilà alors donc nous
avons des financements depuis le départ
sera-t-il possible peut-être que pour
quelques précisions nous puissions
bénéficier des lumières de Baptiste
laroudé mais je vais vous après
peut-être voilà donc quelques petites
quelques petites choses nous avons
depuis la fondation de l'association et
en particulier donc pour cette période
que vous évoquez plusieurs types de
financement nous sommes financés par
exemple par le CNC nous sommes financés
par France 2 nous sommes financés par la
Fondation LVMH par une série d'autres
fondations outre le cipdr donc nous
sommes financés par la dilkra par
également la NCT c'est à dire l'agence
nationale la cohésion des territoires
nous sommes financés par la Région
Île-de-France nous sommes financés par
un certain nombre de départements le 93
le 83 le 71 etc etc pardon le
financement public là dedans donc le
pourcentage puisque
80% de public
c'est beaucoup ce sont beaucoup les
financements publics y compris comme le
disait des régions mais il y a aussi des
mécénates compétences que ce soit le
BETC qui nous a aidé pendant des années
ou même ma propre société cinetv puisque
je suis productrice et qui apporte tout
un toute la comptabilité
toutes ces choses là
les pourcentages m'intéressent mais ce
qui m'intéresse plus c'est aussi le
montant donc au début et aujourd'hui
votre budget annuel
budget annuel on varié au début ça a été
aux alentours des 400000 euros il y a eu
des petits creux notamment 2020 etc
surtout quand on a on faisait beaucoup
d'événementsiels on a beaucoup souffert
du covid et on remonte aujourd'hui
effectivement plutôt entre les 350 000
et 450 000 euros de budget annuel le
fond Marianne représentait une énorme
part de notre budget de l'élector 2022
combien de combien de personnels
salariés on a 2021 on avait cette
salariés et deux stagiaires aujourd'hui
on a 6 salariés trois stagiaires
voilà très bien
et donc aujourd'hui là vous avez une
continuité toujours par le cpdr
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que le fond
Marianne a été bon à un moment donné
une façon de si je vous entends bien
mais je voudrais pas traduire c'est à
vous de dire mais de franchir un gap un
peu les uns les autres dire de monter un
petit peu en puissance capacité à faire
plus et puis ensuite le fond Marianne
disparaissant en fait je suis PDR a
repris son enveloppe enfin reprise sur
son enveloppe propre ces montants là et
les a préservés globalement je veux dire
le problème des associations c'est qu'on
a rarement des financements pluriannuels
donc chaque année nous allons chercher
des sous chercher des sous chercher des
sous donc avec le cipdr certains depuis
2007 nous depuis 2015 et toi je sais
plus quelle année on est allé voir le
cipdr et puis une année le cipda nous a
dit alors on sait pas ce qu'ils vont
nous aider s'ils vont pas nous aider on
raconte ce dont on a besoin ce qu'on
fait et à quel point ils sont importants
bien sûr de notre financement et puis
une année on nous a dit ah mais il va y
avoir un budget spécial pour toutes ces
actions qui va s'appeler le fond
Marianne et donc l'origine des sous est
venu par quelque chose qui s'appelle le
fond Marianne pendant une année et puis
on est retourné au ci PDF c'est comme ça
quelque chose nous nous l'avons vécu et
je pense vous aussi mais il faut
Marianne c'est aussi le cipdr de toute
façon c'est une une appellation on va
dire à ce stade de l'action de sépilaire
et peut-être une occasion effectivement
de monter un petit peu les budgets pour
permettre oui pour pour compléter
monsieur le Président et vous éclairez
sur la manière dont on travaille avec le
CPD en tout cas pour vous faire part de
mon expérience et notre expérience à
conspiration watch lorsque nous avons
une action qui cofinancer et bien nous
faisons des reportings réguliers
en tout cas au moins une fois par mois
parfois chaque semaine ça dépend par
mail et puis parfois on fait des pointes
iconique avec la personne qui s'occupe
de suivre de suivre de projet j'imagine
que c'est pareil avec les autres
associations
à l'approche du renouvellement en tout
cas des demandes de renouvellement donc
en 2021 on nous a dit attendez on va
vous verrez et moi je sais que j'ai
retrouvé ça par mail parce que je l'ai
posé dessus par téléphone avant en fait
je ne sais plus en tout cas je sais que
j'ai eu un mail en date du 28 avril 2021
nous informons du lancement de l'appel à
projet et on a découvert que la période
projet ça faisait huit jours qu'il était
en ligne sur le site du cpdr mais on
s'apprêtait de toute façon à faire une
nouvelle demande voilà donc il faut se
dire que tout ça c'est fait
revenir sur la chronologie on va revenir
sur sur ce point tout à fait bon écoutez
je vous propose que le secrétaire
général de Vienne maintenant sur le le
cadre de l'appel à projet fond Marianne
donc on est un peu plus
j'ai dit secrétaire général
de temps ça m'arrive de temps en temps
c'est comme ça c'est le rapporteur
général pas pourquoi j'appelle
secrétaire merci monsieur le président
oui justement
de d'entre vous sont abordés le fond
Marianne
je voulais juste
on a eu un début de réponse pour l'un
d'entre vous je voulais que chacun vous
nous disiez à quel moment vous avez
entendu parlé du fond Marianne comment
vous en avez eu connaissance
comment pour chacune des associations
qu'elle a été le contact la mise en
relation le en fonction du déroulé
chronologique sur le début d'année 2020
monsieur Demaison des maisons
monsieur le rapporteur général le donc
nous on travaillait on a une réunion le
9 avril avec une interlocute notre
interlocutrice habituelle du seigle
arrière je vais être factuel avant de
levril vous entendez parler de rien moi
j'entends parler du nous on entend
parler du fond le 29 avril
spécifiquement voilà le 29 avril on a
deux mails un mail d'une préfecture qui
publicise le fond en disant il y a un
nouveau fonds
et
quelques heures après on se demande que
c'est que ce fond donc on commence à
s'interroger quelques heures après on
reçoit un mail de notre interlocutrice
habituelle du cipdr nous informons le
lancement de ce fond et nous disons si
vous voulez maximiser vos chances cette
année d'obtenir une subvention c'est là
qu'il faut
déposer votre dossier donc vous avez dit
29 avril mais vous m'avez dit je vous ai
coupé que le 9 avril nous on préparé une
demande de subvention avec notre
interlocutrice habituelle en disant on
aimerait bien été
qui a déjà été nommé par Monsieur
monsieur Bidart d'accord
parce qu'il y en a entendu parler du
fond marin beaucoup plus tôt j'ai
entendu donc je
alors au plus tôt donc je vois donc sur
les documents que nous avons rassemblés
que le 25 mars 2021 nous avons fait
parvenir nos demandes de subvention qui
était lié pas seulement au projet de
discours fraternel en ligne mais à un
projet éducatif de la mallette
pédagogique donc nous l'avons transmis
de 25 mars au cipdr et c'est à la suite
de cette transmission le 25 mars que le
cipdr nous a proposé d'intégrer notre
demande de subvention pour le projet de
discours fraternel en ligne à l'appel à
projet fond Marianne voilà qui venait de
se créer
en nous précisant bien que
et bien il nous appelait à trouver
d'autres interlocuteurs c'est à dire
d'autres financeurs pour ce qui concerne
la mallette pédagogique
ce que nous avons essayé de faire
une précision peut-être de date qui va
apporter une précision
c'est pas le jour même le 25 mars qu'on
nous a parlé pour la première fois du
fond de Rennes le 25 mars c'est la
dernière c'est la c'est le moment où on
a envoyé nos demandes de subvention
après beaucoup de choses ont été au
téléphone avec Charlotte Collonge et
c'est plus tard et je peux retrouver
dans mes mails maintenant si vous
motorisez sur mon téléphone qu'on nous a
dit on intègre à l'appel à projet comme
rien dont vous a parlé c'était plutôt
courant avril
donc vous en entendez parler au mois de
mars parce qu'il y en a un d'entre vous
je suis en train de chercher mes notes
qui m'a parlé de janvier nous en janvier
on a demandé un rendez-vous enfin on a
fait le rendez-vous avec la comment on
fait un peu tous les ans et notamment
pour présenter cette volonté de
nouvelles actions sur les réseaux
sociaux auprès du cpdr du secrétaire
général du cpdr ensuite on arrive on a
obtenu aussi un rendez-vous avec le
cabinet de Madame la ministrehapa pour
présenter notre association en général
et sans nous dire qu'il allait avoir des
financements particuliers ou quoi
vous faites un lien entre le cpdr et le
cabinet de la ministre on a rendez-vous
qu'on a eu avec les gens du cabinet de
la ministre il y avait aussi monsieur le
préfet Christian gravelle qui était
présent
c'était pour présenter justement nos
actions dans dans les domaines qui
étaient sous la responsabilité de la
ministre de l'Égalité des Chances et en
fait le 25 mars on a envoyé nos
propositions de subvention mi-avril on
nous a dit ah bah ça va rentrer dans
l'appel à projet fond marine
et à partir de ce moment-là puisque
pour quand même croiser les informations
dont on dispose on a comité de
programmation le 13 avril
T1 le 20 avril on a la publication et le
10 mai on a la sélection donc pour les
uns pour les autres
quel est votre calendrier respectif
s de précisément c'est-à-dire
vous entendez parler d'informations
après il faut déposez parce que j'ai des
dates qui varient moi j'essaie de juste
de comprendre parce qu'après il faudra
recoller ce que les uns les autres
à partir de quand certains visiblement
d'entre vous de ce que vous nous dites
là ont des informations
avant même le comité de programmation
d'autres plutôt après j'ai entendu le 29
donc j'essaie de savoir de comprendre
comment dans un délai qui est déjà très
contraint comment les choses se
déroulent pour les uns et pour les
autres parce que il y a quand même
derrière vous êtes vous avez la
représentants de la Commission des
finances donc on essaie aussi de
comprendre comment les choses sont
ordonnées quel est le respect des
procédures et qu'elle est dans un temps
dont je reconnais qu'il est très court
mais parfois j'ai l'impression à vous
entendre qu'il est presque encore
comprimé accéléré donc juste savoir à
quel moment vous avez vraiment la
formation à quel moment vous avez
présenté le dossier et à quel moment
vous l'avez déposé et à quel moment il a
été définitivement accepté
pour bien
compléter il y a la question de par
exemple vous nous dites on a présenté un
dossier en amont tout à fait et
finalement vous a dit après ce dossier
sera traité fort mariage autrement dit
la question par exemple vous concernant
c'est est-ce que vous allez déposé un
autre dossier ou non c'est le même qui
finalement a répondu à l'appel d'offre
qui a été qualifiée pour après appel
d'offre vous voyez ce que je veux dire
sans que vous ayez besoin de redéposer
après formellement après l'appel d'offre
est-ce que vous allez redéposé
formellement ou pas non c'est le même
c'est le même monsieur des maisons
nous je
ne déléguais généralement on voit un
petit WhatsApp pour me préciser donc
nous on dépose un dossier
fipdr le 9 avril enfin c'est ce que je
vais l'impression de recevoir et le 29
avril du coup on apprend
labellisé font Marianne on apprend qu'il
y a un fond Marianne et du coup il a je
n'ai pas le calendrier il a été fléché
sur le fond Marianne sans avoir été
spécifiquement refait par rapport à un
appel d'offre non c'est votre dossier
c'était notre projet
c'était notre projet mais vous avez la
sélection officielle alors j'ai le 26
mai nous obtenons une réponse informelle
le 18 juin nous avons une annonce
officielle
voilà très bien sur la chaîne donc nous
nous avons reçu un mail du cipdr le 28
avril 2021
nous avons fait mais a prioritaire la
demande de subventions dans le cadre de
l'appel à projet nous avons envoyé nos
dossiers candidature le 7 mai 2021 et
nous avons reçu pareil un mail du cpdr
nous informer notre projet était retenu
le 18 juin 2021 et par la suite
nous avons reçu un courrier officiel de
Marlène Schiappa le 16 juillet 2021 mais
le courrier en pièce jointe était daté
du 4 juin 2021 alors il a dû être envoyé
par ailleurs en Barrois postal on a dû
le récupérer mais là je peux vous dire
ce qu'on a dans notre boîte mail parce
qu'on a on n'a pas épluché les autres
les autres documents voilà est-ce que
vous diriez que vous avez construit une
proposition par rapport au cahier des
charges oui oui on sait oui on s'est
calé alors
absolument parce que l'idée de de faire
coïncider le plus possible notre projet
au cahier des charges de l'appel à
projet par définition pour maximiser nos
chances d'être retenu
il se trouve que on a je vous le disais
on a ajusté notre notre projet riposte
pardon je pense que excusez-moi je pense
que vous avez pas eu le choix parce que
29 avril ou déployer cette mai vous êtes
sans le savoir sélectionner le 10 mai
c'est oui mais on s'attend chaque année
à cette période là je vais faire une
demande de subvention quand même pas de
rien et puis on est on était fort de
deux années d'expérience
d'expérimentation de cette de cette
action
ce qui me conduit à penser que les
délais alors les informations variables
selon vos trois associations en termes
de pré-information ou d'annonces autour
du fond mariage comme de toute façon
vous œuvrez sur ce secteur là depuis des
années qu'effectivement j'entends comme
toutes les assurances chaque année il
faut ajuster le tir ça ne vous a pas
surpris outre mesure d'avoir des délais
ou et à la fois peut-être un peu un
manque de visibilité mais des délais
très courts pour répondre et ajuster
oui je peux si je peux me permettre et
pour aller tout à fait dans votre sens
vous l'avez compris pour nous
manifestement on est dans le même cas le
cipdr est depuis des années un
interlocuteur régulier avec lesquels
lequel la discussion se réengage pour
ajuster chaque année voilà et c'est sur
cette discussion qui s'était réengagée
c'est la date que je vous ai donnée le
18 janvier 2021 et donc comme tous les
ans devient de nouveau sous le soleil
donc on réengage la discussion on se met
d'accord avec le cipdr sur ce qui
constitue nous notre valeur ajoutée
c'est à dire ce qu'on sait faire ce
qu'on est capable de faire et là petit à
petit on prépare le projet et puis
quelques mois plus tard et effectivement
là on va vous retrouver les dates
exactes pour préciser à notre tour et
bien le cipdr nous fait savoir que nous
pouvons candidater en effet pour ce fond
et entendu pardon que chaque année vous
fournissez des comptes rendus qu'il vous
sont demandés tout à fait qui a
éventuellement du dialogue ok vous y
ajouter pardon oui oui je voulais
simplement ajouter avec quand même un
élément nouveau qui est un contexte
lourd lié à ce qui s'est passé en
octobre 2020 c'est-à-dire qu'on a tous
ça en tête à cette époque là quand même
je j'entends que vous avez centaines
mais ce qu'on a parfois du mal à voir
c'est
la ligne de la une frontière si j'allais
dire entre l'annonce du fond Marianne
les appels à projets je dirais
habituel et puis cet appel à projet au
regard effectivement d'une annonce dont
le préfet Gravel a expliqué qu'il y a
une décision politique de leur créer un
fond Marianne en fait de plutôt
labelliser une partie de la dotation
sous la forme de fond Marianne annoncée
à 2 millions 5 et qui finit un peu plus
de 2 millions donc c'est tout moi je
vous dis j'essaie juste de comprendre
et il va être somme sur rapporteur que
le programme r du FIPD donc les crédits
fléchés sur la lutte contre
radicalisation ils l'ont été dans un
contexte post attentat c'est à dire que
il s'est passé des choses dans ce pays
en 2015 2016 et ensuite il y a pas eu
uniquement cet événement tragique de de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine donc
si vous voulez
si vous voulez on parlera tout à l'heure
de la question si ça vous intéresse du
séparatisme comment on l'envisage de
comment le complotisme parce que nous
c'est notre créneau la lutte contre
argumentative contre les discours
complotistes comment ça s'articule avec
la lutte contre radicalisation il y a
toute une littérature là-dessus quand
même assez bien solide qui montre que
c'est une passerelle et l'antichambre
vers la radicalisation l'extrémisme y
compris l'extrémisme violent mais bon je
déflure peut-être un peu trop tôt les
choses mais si vous voulez moi j'ai pas
de souci j'ai simplement vous êtes trois
associations là vous n'avez pas la même
antériorité il y a une association qui a
une quinzaine d'années une dizaine et
une 5-6 ans donc moi j'essaie de
comprendre c'est tout c'est pas c'est
dernier élément ce qui me concerne dans
la réalisation du projet puisque vous
l'avez évoqué chaque année forcément on
essaie d'avoir le budget qui soit en
regard des actions à conduire avec des
équipes et notamment donc des personnels
est-ce que
le fond Marianne a vous a conduit les
uns ou les autres à augmenter vos
effectifs pour mieux répondre ou parce
que vous n'aviez pas forcément les
bonnes compétences puisque on a bien
compris que il fallait rentrer sur un
contact public jeune digital et
j'ai entendu ce que Monsieur Bidard a
dit sur les différents modes de
communication notamment pour toucher les
jeunes avec des spécialistes du sujet
donc vous vous avez répondu avec
quelques postes cette monsieur des
maisons monsieur le rapporteur
dans mon autre vie qui est ma vie
professionnelle et pas de bénévole je
dirige des entreprises et donc je me
méfie toujours de faire une embauche sur
un fond d'une année
dont la reconductibilité et
peut-être probable mais vraiment très
incertaine et dont mon expérience se dit
qu'elle varie dans le temps donc nous
avions comme projet en revanche on aime
on a envie d'être dynamique donc nous
avions comme projet dans le cas du fond
Marianne de faire une embauche
supplémentaire
parce que le monde les montants qui nous
étaient alloués étaient importants et
que donc nous voulions être sûr que
tout allait très bien se passer avec ces
vérité
on n'a pas réussi à faire cette embauche
et donc nous avons du coup
moins dépenser cette année là donc pas
dépenser l'intégralité de la somme qui
nous était alloué voilà embauche sera
peut-être faite dans les prochaines les
prochains mois je sais pas si j'ai
répondu mais voilà
oui oui vous avez répondu pas d'embauche
nous concernant nous sommes deux
salariés un troisième a été embauché en
CDD en décembre dernier et une quatrième
en février 2023
décembre 2022
l'action financée dans le cadre du fond
Marianne nous étions 7 à intervenir
dessus
ma binôme Valérie Gounet moi-même dans
tous les deux salariés deux prestataires
ont la personne de Tristan Mendès France
qui est au pilote de cette action
précisément un journaliste
et trois stagiaires ont participé à des
moments différents à l'action également
mais enfin et j'en conclus que vous êtes
resté effectivement constant
voulait dire en équivalent temps oui oui
non mais oui
on a besoin de nous d'être factuel sur
pour comprendre voilà en revanche en
revanche nous avons des caissé des
prestations des rémunérations voilà qui
qu'on n'aurait pas autrement si je peux
rebondir pardon le nous pour être très
précis donc une partie de nos actions
repose sur des jeunes réalisateurs qu'on
va mobiliser sur le terrain qu'ils ont
des spécialistes de la réalisation de
cours long métrage qui est en cas des
ateliers dont pour faire créer des
vidéos avec des publics jeunes on a
doublé le nombre de réalisateurs qu'on a
pu mobiliser et donc formé et qui par
moments doivent continuer même à
faire ce format d'atelier certains voilà
très bien monsieur Bidart vous aviez
micro
donc outre les précisions qui ont déjà
été apportées nous avons eu
l'opportunité à ce moment-là de salariés
5 personnes supplémentaires donc pour
nous vraiment c'était quelque chose de
très important
que je souhaiterais aussi restaurer
surligner sur le sur le temps long enfin
un petit peu plus long ça a été
rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure la
période covid a été extrêmement
difficile pour le pour le monde
associatif et elle a non seulement été
difficile mais elle a été véritablement
le moment d'une prise de conscience la
prise de conscience était que il y a une
il y avait une fragilité très forte à
organiser des événements en présence
ciel comme on dit aujourd'hui voilà et
cela nous a convaincu dans la réflexion
où l'on court que nous avons au sein de
l'association qu'il fallait faire un
surcroît d'effort justement au niveau de
la présence sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est-à-dire au niveau de ce qui est
numérique des matérialisé voilà et donc
c'est dans ce contexte là que
véritablement cette opportunité en a été
une de salariés 5 personnes
supplémentaires et de constituer une
équipe donc au total une équipe baptise
je parle sur ton contrôle de cette
personne qui a été active comme je l'ai
décris sur les réseaux sociaux à partir
alors est-ce que ça s'appelle une
plateforme qui s'appelle le bon côté des
choses le BCDC n'en sait pas une
plateforme c'est-à-dire qu'on a créé si
vous voulez enfin on a utilisé un outil
Haddock que je vais laisser Baptiste
d'écrire
c'est juste dans les différentes
stratégies qu'on évoquait pour réussir à
intéresser ce public ce qui a certes
beaucoup d'appétence pour pour plein de
sujets sociétés mais qui est très
volatile qui est le public jeune sur les
réseaux sociaux il fallait un nom un peu
plus jeune que fraternité générale ça
leur plaisait pas du tout donc on a
baissé d'essai pour bon côté des choses
mais c'est juste le nom des comptes
Instagram et Tik Tok de fraternité
générale
et l'équipe est depuis on a toujours
cette équipe là on a
adapté certains postes en fonction de
l'évolution qu'on a vu notamment avec
les
rapports mensuels qu'on fait au cpdr et
qu'on fait depuis le début de toutes les
actions on a vu que bon bah empêcher un
peu là-dedans etc et donc maintenant on
a une équipe de 4 salariés et trois
stagiaires qui s'occupent de nos actions
sur les réseaux sociaux si je peux le
permettre on a ça nous a conduit à
définir un périmètre d'action fraternité
que nous voulions valoriser et au sein
de se BCDC donc de ce bon côté des
choses
on a défini 9 thématiques je voulais
cite rapidement à la volée l'engagement
des jeunes les valeurs de la République
les enjeux sociaux c'est-à-dire toutes
les questions de société qui sont liées
à ce que j'évoquais au départ c'est à
dire toutes les séparations sociales la
tolérance l'égalité femme homme et le
genre l'écologie là il était évident en
particulier avec ces deux derniers
sujets que il était nécessaire d'aller
du côté du discours vers quelque chose
qui parle immédiatement aux jeunes
les nouveaux outils et les enjeux de
communication la cancelle culture les
fake news les théories du complot le
gaming le cyber-harcèlement etc etc
autant de
néologisme un peu baroque le
fonctionnement de l'appareil républicain
toujours encré ça dans une culture
républicaine la transmission d'une
culture républicaine et puis tous les
savoirs liés à la fraternité vous voyez
par exemple aujourd'hui les
neurosciences sont capables de vous dire
que tel comportement va développer telle
zone neuronale qui a son tour va
encourager la conduite de l'être humain
dans tel ou telle direction voilà des
choses comme ça les porter dans un
langage accessible à la connaissance des
jeunes générations
très bien moi j'aurai une dernière
question
à mon avis une double question donc si
vous avez des éléments
plus précis que ce que vous avez donné
là pour s'il y a eu des évolutions
d'effectifs liés à au fond Marianne et
puis après à son effacement qui ont
modifié les
effectifs de vos associations faites les
nous suivre ça nous permet de mieux
comprendre ce que je rappelle quand même
que nous sommes sur le fond Marianne
lequel
ayant s'étend éteint au bout d'un an je
peux entendre que ce que vous avez dit
les uns les autres que ça entraîne un
pilotage qui n'est pas forcément
toujours évident en restant affectif
constant ou alors en répondant à
d'autres appels à projets voilà c'est
donc juste est-ce que
ce comment dirait cet appel à projet se
font Marianne sont sa création et son
extinction est-ce que ça finalement
répondu à vos attentes une fois vous
avez été sélectionné ce que vous y avez
trouvé
je dirais ce que vous en espériez ou
attendiez
on espérait un co-financement d'une
action qu'on aurait menée de toute façon
avec un impact et une ampleur moindre
mais mais c'est une action qu'on mène de
toute façon donc
oui dans la mesure où ça s'est bien
passé où l'administration nous a donné
qui tue ou
on a été on a fait une nouvelle demande
et où on a été cette demande a été
acceptée de nouveau
oui vous savez nous on pense que
l'État ne peut pas tout faire que la
société civile peut pas tout faire non
plus l'état dans cette
dans cette politique de lutte contre les
conditions pour que la société civile
prenne ses responsabilités face ce qui
lui ne peut pas faire je crois ce point
de vue le bilan en tout cas pour nous il
est positif on a été accompagné et on
continue à l'être voilà
monsieur Bidart oui peut-être pour aller
dans dans ce sens alors la réponse est
décidément oui et également mais j'irai
sur le fond d'une conviction que je
pense nous partageons tous qui est que
les initiatives comme la nôtre qui
viennent de la société civile sont tout
à fait heureuses de trouver en trouver
en face d'elle une volonté qui est une
volonté politique qui puisse venir au
soutien et au soutien de laquelle elles
peuvent elles-mêmes venir pour faire
vivre ces fameuses valeurs donc lorsque
de manière un peu sèche nous parlons de
financement qui viennent de différentes
provenances publiques privées en réalité
nous parlons d'un effort collectif dans
la direction de ces de ces valeurs qui
nous importent donc il y avait là pour
nous toutes les conditions de la
confiance je dirais avec ce comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation
merci j'ai des maisons la réponse est
aussi oui
ça nous a donné l'occasion enfin de
travailler un cofinancement avec la NCT
on est content des objectifs qu'on a
atteint nos objectifs et donc on était
content d'être plus allant mais de
pouvoir quand même réussir ce qu'on
avait dit qu'on ferait ça nous a permis
de tester des nouveaux formats donc
d'être un petit peu challenger pardon
pour l'anglicisme mais il y a eu cette
il y a eu ce quand même ce travail là
évidemment au joint ce que disait madame
servant Schreiber le nous le sujet du
pluriel est a toujours été
le sujet parce que dans le numérique
évidemment le les si on veut créer des
communautés développer des communautés
il faut mettre du contenu régulièrement
il faut engager les personnes qui vous
suivent qu'il faut pouvoir leur répondre
si à un moment vous arrêtez et que vous
attendez trois mois six mois
sur un projet vous vous avez perdu un
petit peu le bénéfice de cette dy là
donc c'est sûr qu'en pilotage c'est pas
l'absolu perfection mais on a été on a
accueilli avec avec joie enfin ce
dispositif merci et merci Monsieur sur
ces points là qui sont des points
importants parce qu'effectivement la
plus annuelle c'est toujours le point
difficile avec l'État qui par nature un
budget annuel il est même voté dans
cette maison pour partie donc
on est pour partir responsable en tout
cas c'est notre mode de fonctionnement
et et effectivement ça oblige à
apprendre les choses assez tôt
finalement pour relancer les mécaniques
et pour vérifier qu'on puisse aller sur
le long terme d'autant plus que des
actions comme les vôtres on le sait bien
bon elles appellent plusieurs années de
fonctionnement de toute façon pour être
utile pour être en tout cas efficace
donc ça nous paraît assez clair alors on
voudrait revenir sur quelques sujets
alors on n'est pas très surpris de vous
répondre puisque finalement
ce que vous nous dites c'est un travail
avec depuis quelques années à disciples
un moment donné le financement c'est un
peu les fonds mariage très bien on
revient dans le financement classique si
PDR mais au niveau qui ont été montés
par le fond Marianne et donc bon
finalement voilà ça fonctionne bon c'est
ce que vous avez dit me semble-t-il
un point sur l'échange avec les
interlocuteurs là vous avez dit qu'il y
avait une espèce de continuité mensuelle
etc nous on a cruauté qui avait eu une
variation en fait avec le départ de la
personne que vous avez cité c'est-à-dire
en décembre 2021 il n'y a plus la
responsable chargée justement du suivi
et ça se répartit entre trois ou quatre
personnes est-ce que
vous dites bah il s'est rien passé on a
eu des contacts avec des gens qui
étaient tout à fait formés clairs et les
choses sont bien passées où est-ce que
quand même il y a eu une petite rupture
alors qui veut démarrer le sur ce point
allez-y n'hésitez pas oui effectivement
au départ de Madame Collonges nous ce
qui a eu en moins c'est qu'on avait plus
et super newsletter qui nous informer un
peu de l'État et de la littérature sur
la lutte contre la radicalisation que
nous envoyait régulièrement par contre
on a continué à envoyer des rapports
mensuels à la personne qui nous a été
désigné en expliquant nos
résultats nos écueils on avait
effectivement peut-être un peu moins de
retour que quand c'était la personne de
Charlotte Collonge mais on n'était pas
non plus on n'a pas senti le CVR absent
pour autant et depuis on nous donne un
résultat rétribuer une vraiment qui est
depuis un moment on la période de Madame
c'est une période où il y a une période
le sépilaire le dit
il y a eu un peu de flottement parce que
la personne qui est en charge et qui
connaissait bien en réalité puisqu'elle
était là depuis des années sur cette
thématique
est partie et donc à ce moment-là -là il
y a eu quelques quelques moments un peu
de flottement enfin ça a pas été en tout
cas pour vous ça a pas changé la manière
dont vous travaillez à laisser payer
vous avez envoyé vos rapports ils ont
peut-être été moins regardés j'en sais
rien mais bon ça n'a pas changé
fondamentalement la relation c'est ce
que vous me dites
avec Provence cette phase de transition
effectivement
même chose effectivement alors je vous
voyez je répète juste spontanément dater
le départ de la chaîne de mission dont
on évoquait à l'instant sans doute un
moment un peu de trou d'air dans nos
relations avec ces pays d'air mais il
faut bien que vous ayez à l'esprit que
nous qu'à nous singulièrement nous
sommes une toute petite structure et que
l'essentiel ne travaille
ça n'est pas de parler au cipdr en
réalité on le faisait avec cette
personne régulièrement parce que on
faisait des points on envoyait des des
on s'envoyait des mails je vous dis au
moins une fois par mois mais
le cœur de notre travail c'est quand
même nos sujets c'est quand même ce
qu'on fait c'est à dire une rédaction
qui travaille sur la question du
complotisme etc donc je dois vous dire
que
ça a été presque indolore quoi après on
a trouvé d'autres interlocuteurs
effectivement maintenant il y a une
personne au cpdr qui est en charge
d'ailleurs des questions de complotisme
spécifiquement avec qui on échange voilà
mais vous comprendrez bien que de notre
point de vue on le regarde si je puis
dire par l'autre côté du miroir
c'est-à-dire que ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de savoir comment des opérations
de cette nature sur lequel il y a une
communication extrêmement forte au
moment du lancement avec des objectifs
présentés de manière extrêmement
ambitieuse ou ambitieux pour les
objectifs excusez-moi et finalement
comment se fait le suivi pour être sûr
qu'on est dans les clous c'est quelque
chose d'important
et donc évidemment on comprend
et c'est pour ça que nous avons pris
nous avons souhaité avoir certes des
auditions avec vous le savez des
associations
sur le fonctionnement a été un peu plus
erratique on s'en tiendra là avant de
les avoir entendus et des associations
quand une habitude de travail le cpdr
mais pour nous c'est pas tout à fait
comment dire sans importance que de
savoir que même si vous vous êtes
évidemment dans votre job si je puis
dire et dans votre rôle bien la relation
au cpdr et d'une certaine façon le
contrôle des contenus
bien le sujet qui peut toucher certaines
associations
se fait bien correctement par le cipdr
voyez tout au long même quel que soit la
confiance qui a pu être établi avec les
uns et les autres dans la durée voilà
pourquoi on insiste un peu un peu sur ce
point
alors
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
considéré aussi vous l'avez vous avez
déjà un peu répondu évidemment
un dialoguant on double un peu les
questions mais on va les reprendre sur
un autre un autre axe ou un autre angle
le fond Marianne il a été prévu pour un
an en tant que tel on a vu qu'ensuite il
était repris pour les associations en
tout cas qui étaient considérées comme
ayant fait un bon travail il était
repris par le cpdr bon mais c'était une
version un an est-ce que ça vous
paraissait
réaliste solide sérieux de pouvoir
montrer en un an qu'on faisait des
choses utiles et où est-ce que
finalement bon il faudra un peu plus
d'un an
peut-être même trois ans pour arriver à
prouver que on a atteint sa cible donc
est-ce que finalement il y avait une
bonne comment dire une bonne
programmation de la chose
ce qui nous a rassuré en termes de
programmation malgré la fragilité que
vous évoquez de quelque chose qui est là
pour un an c'est que ne l'oublions pas
c'était un appel à projet qui se faisait
sur le fond d'une relation durable avec
le cipdr donc quand bien même le fond
disparaissait au bout d'un an et bien la
relation avec le cipdr perdurer donc
effectivement en soi c'était assez
fragile mais nous avons nous avions
alors deux choses je dirais d'une part
nous avions bon espoir que il s'agissait
là d'un épisode supplémentaire qui
consoliderait encore notre relation avec
le cipdr et puis d'autre part comme le
disait madame Servan-Schreber nous
sommes retrouvés finalement confrontés à
une fragilité à laquelle malheureusement
nous avons l'habitude ou dans
malheureusement nous avons l'habitude
c'est à dire que chaque année nous avons
besoin d'aller taper à la porte d'un
certain nombre d'interlocuteurs de les
sensibiliser à notre démarche et je
dirais que c'est toujours un mal pour un
bien c'est à dire que c'est une
situation qui est fragile qui un secure
mais en même temps ça nous oblige nous
également à revoir notre discours c'est
à dire que quand vous le savez bien
quand quelque chose roule ça devient
paresseux voilà donc c'est un exercice
également et nous le prenions comme tel
donc il y avait pas d'inquiétude
particulière d'autant moins que en
réalité c'est la même chose au niveau du
contenu c'est-à-dire nous avions
l'opportunité d'en mettre un coup si
vous me passez l'expression dans notre
casque fort sur les réseaux sociaux mais
pour nous c'était un projet au long
cours donc de toute façon nous avions la
je dirais le projet de le faire
continuer en essayant de trouver les
financements nécessaires
oui j'ajoute que sur les 5 critères de
sélection de l'appel à projet on a bien
celui de la pérennité de l'action je
suis en train de le relire une attention
particulière sera portée au projet
réunissant des co-financement favorisant
la pérennité des projets au-delà 2021
nous c'était notre cas puisque encore
une fois l'essentiel à la majorité notre
financement et de financement privé
c'est pour l'essentiel une subvention
annuelle de la Fondation pour les morts
de la Shoah qui est une fondation privée
d'utilité publique
voilà donc j'imagine que dans l'esprit
des rédacteurs il y avait l'idée d'une
pérennité d'un accompagnement alors pas
plus réelle au sens propre mais c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a qu'on l'a compris en
tout cas d'accord donc vous êtes en
train de nous donner un petit peu un des
critères qui auraient permis de vous
retenir puisque comme on n'a pas de
critères
on n'a pas de grille par association des
critères retenus j'ai entendu les
auditions précédentes mais en
l'occurrence l'appel à projet précise
bien cinq critères
il y a des critères mais après on n'a
pas de notation sur ces critères donc on
n'en sait pas beaucoup plus donc vous
avez donné un élément c'est que vous
vous aviez vous un projet qui
s'inscrivait dans cette vision
pluriannuelle en tout cas dans le temps
avec peut-être des niveaux plus ou moins
fort selon les les soutiens mais en tout
cas vous restiez sur cette ligne très
bien
on va terminer avec Monsieur des maisons
la poursivique FAB donc il y a eu un
avenant qui a été signé pour vous
donc pourquoi ce délai supplémentaire
jusqu'au 30 juin 2022 a-t-il été
sollicité peut-être parce que l'action a
démarré plus tard enfin vous allez nous
le dire et puis sylvic Fab vous avez été
le finalement le premier à avoir fait
l'objet d'un contrôle alors c'est pour
une raison une erreur semble-t-il du
cpdr en tout cas ils l'ont présenté
comme ça ils ont ils vous ont donné trop
tôt enfin des financements peu importe
donc c'est pas sur le fond mais par
contre du coup comment se contrôle
s'est-il déroulé et quelles en étaient
les conclusions
je rebondis sur le point précédent le le
il y a toujours une question de la du
moment de versement de la subvention
pour nous c'est septembre 2021
pour la première partie pour la première
partie c'est à dire que pour celles ceux
qui étaient en démarrage d'association
je sais pas comment ça s'est passé pour
elle mais il est sûr que il est il est
difficile d'engager des fonds avec un
petit délai je crois pas que ça enfin
c'est un point à garder en tête pour
nous aussi qui avons
un peu plus de fonds de roulement pas
beaucoup mais un peu et une capacité à
escalader entre guillemets puisqu'on a
des bénévoles et s'il y a besoin on peut
monter on est déjà beaucoup de gens
compétents pour pouvoir faire les
actions on a une expérience on a on a ce
qu'il faut voilà
donc ça c'était mon petit mon petit
modulo dans le grand dans le dans la
discussion sur laquelle je suis d'accord
voilà
nous le on a demandé effectivement une
prorogation de mars à juin 2022 de notre
subvention ce qui est quelque chose que
ma délégué général diffère de façon
classique pas forcément systématique
mais pas
particulièrement enfin ça n'a pas
surprise particulièrement
on est sur une année covid on a des
événements et donc il y a un salon
d'événements qui ont pas pu se tenir en
première partie d'année parce que il y
avait à l'époque est-ce que je fais un
événement est-ce que je serai obligé de
le fermer enfin on a tous connu ça tous
toutes et donc du coup l'essentiel
beaucoup de nos événements notre
festival de du court métrage qui
rassemble un jeune public qui a produit
des vidéos qui revient avec ses amis ses
parents qui valent les diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux ce festival on a pu le
faire qu'en juin un autre atelier enfin
un autre compte-rendu de notre événement
mémorama qu'on a fait réussir qui était
une exposition d'oeuvres sur le sujet de
la mémoire et d'histoire la guerre
d'Algérie on a pu les faire aussi que
allaiter voilà donc on a demandé
effectivement ce décalage là
il est possible que du coup ça a pu
susciter une question c'est le seul
échange que j'ai eu par mail
avec Monsieur Lafitte donc on lui a
enfin notre délégué général lui a
demandé une prorogation il a répondu en
nous demandant une date
et en notant que on pouvait pas aller
jusqu'à décembre au-delà de décembre
2022 et on lui a répondu qu'on
s'arrêterait en juin 2022 ce qu'on a
fait et donc on a réalisé 100% de nos
actions prévues à juin 2022 voilà pour
ce qui est du contrôle donc
effectivement on a été les heureux
gagnants du premier contrôle
écoutez nous personne nous a dit quoi
que ce soit donc alors j'ai juste on a
reçu un petit email
début décembre
2022 d'une agente du cipdr qui nous l'a
présenté je la cite dans la continuité
de campagne de 2019 de contrôle interne
financier de subventions octroyés sur le
FIPD par le SGS cipdr voilà donc nous
avons reçu un mail présentant ce
contrôle comme un contrôle dans la
continuité et nous informons d'autres
dossiers étaient sélectionnés pour ce
contrôle nous demandons d'envoyer nos
pièces
avant si possible 16 décembre ce que
nous avons fait pour l'essentiel il nous
restait quelques pièces à numériser les
vacances passant et quelques pièces sont
arrivées en janvier et je saurais pas
vous dire la date précise mais voilà
donc j'avais pas eu d'alerte je n'ai pas
eu d'appel personne m'a donné quelques
indication que ce soit sur le fait que
je
devais être contrôlé je n'ai pas eu non
plus d'éléments d'information
sur les résultats de ce contrôle
je sais que le
cipdr nous a reconduit enfin nous a
proposé d'accepter une un nouveau
dossier de subvention donc j'imagine que
si nous avions eu facile à identifier
des problèmes je pense que on l'aurait
su
j'ai pas été surpris complètement par ça
parce que dans le passé donc mon
comptable m'a confirmé quand même que le
LG cipdr appelé directement l'appeler
directement donc on a un cabinet
comptable et donc pour
identifier telle pièce savoir avoir une
précision sur telle ou telle facture
pas systématiquement mais plusieurs fois
et aussi quelques points sur des points
formels mettons précisé dans le passé
voilà
ce que je peux dire sur ce sujet merci
Monsieur des maisons merci à tous les
madame et à vous messieurs avant de
conclure je vais demander mais c'est pas
très facile pour nos collègues
évidemment de rentrer peut-être dans
cette discussion qui était une
discussion sur le mode de fonctionnement
presque habituel si je puis dire entre
une association et le cipdr qui se
déroule sur le temps long est-ce que
vous avez mes chers collègues quelques
questions à poser à nous inviter
je n'en vois pas donc ça veut dire que
le rapporteur général et moi-même
avons posé les questions qui qui
s'imposaient merci d'y avoir répondu
très très clairement et
[Musique]
très largement vous pouvez nous envoyer
évidemment des compléments
si vous le souhaitez en plus de
documents que vous avez déjà fait passer
mais par rapport aux questions qu'on
vous a posées si cela vous paraît
utile en tout cas merci de nous avoir
rejoint pour cette audition
merci